is a real theater kid energy in certain
parts of the comedy community right now
and uh I will say that there's a lot of
unearned what's the word jubilance is
that a word
jubilant people are very happy this is
my problem
I look at people sometimes they're very
happy well they think they're doing
something well they're happy things are
going well but a lot of this is I was an
actress which I wasn't in high school
theater okay you talentless [ __ ] I
was a real actor I was on Sesame Street
and before you laugh at that you fat
checks you bunch of fat chicks trying to
get attention for the first time of your
goddamn life
understand that I got paid up a lot and
not often but I was paid I was in real
play that real people wrote and yes some
of them killed themselves afterwards
that's what playwrights do they take
themselves out okay they don't go to jfl
and dance run they blow their brains out
New York was a great city I was in a
show called lake of fire no I'm sorry I
wasn't that but I was in another show
called Christmas dreamers awakened it
was about a woman who was raped by her
father repeatedly and it was in the
village when the village was cool it had
little black box theaters and I was in
this I think I was eight or nine or
something I don't even know what I did I
just kind of sat there well the main
character went on and just just hinted
about her dad raping her she never fully
but it was pretty if you if you were
intelligent you knew what was going on
her father came to the show and he sat
there through the whole thing it was
clear that the main character was his
daughter and that he was the rapist he
molested everybody and she said what do
you think afterwards and he went I
thought it was good it was a little long
and that and now that's been replaced in
Manhattan by theater kids theater kids
with PR departments behind them singing
and everything and there's what I feel
about it there's some real talent out
there even people I disagree with on
pretty much everything there's some very
talented people out there but
there's there's a theater kid energy and
the theater kid energy is kind of like
we're the [ __ ]
who cares doesn't matter
we're the new hot thing we're great we
live in this bubble we enjoy it and it's
all fine what I'm telling you I'm gonna
tell you this there there is I don't
care what is going on at the moment for
anybody there are so many talented
people in New York City who you'll just
never see you'll never hear from and
they will die underappreciated
unappreciated alone ah and just you know
what think about them a little bit think
about them a little bit when you're
doing your interviews and your ass
meaningless questions by some other goon
whose job it is to you know and just
realize that you're lucky that Joan
Rivers said some people out there a
[ __ ] very lucky your vet your your a
whole lot of fine you're a whole lot of
fine you didn't invent [ __ ] it ain't
great it in a riot when you perform like
people aren't stopping to get their
money back
usually cuz no money was exchanged but
just know that that's where it's at dogs
relax okay I will say a quote that
someone said it made me a little upset
they said when people copy me you know
what I say I say thank you but you no
one's copying you cuz you've done
nothing and I don't mean that in a dick
way cuz this person I'm talking about I
think
there's talent there but you've done not
you've inspired no one you've done
nothing cut it out
just just relax enjoy what's happening
enjoy where you're at and realize
there's a cashier at CVS who is so much
more talented than you'll ever be and
she's got three kids and a husband that
beats her and you are in a position
to be fine and have everyone love it
just know that that's where it's at
don't get crazy be happy i listen to
could people could say the same thing
about me i am fine there's guys that are
funnier than me that'll never get
certain opportunities i've gotten and i
try to think about that i try to think
about a [ __ ] up life is not all the
time because you got a you know you
can't i'm not saying but certain people
to go out there and there's this just
real attitude that uh they've been
around for about five minutes and they
act like they've changed the game
they've changed the game and five
minutes ago if they were boof nobody
knew gone who didn't know but now
they're here and they've revolutionized
everything de gutenberg with the
printing press they came out and they
gave people the idea that they could
live there's people out there that they
now believe they can be like me and live
and it's such a it's such an honor to
inspire people creative can you cut it
out nobody nobody is out there it's a
mirage it's a black box nobody's in with
some fat chick from Ohio's now gonna
move to New York she was going to anyway
she was coming anyway stop just be happy
I come for the world to feed a real
theater not mommy and daddy paid money
for camps and they paid money for
publicist real [ __ ] theater great
people that aren't art [ __ ] tremendous
and none of them succeeded then they all
end up [ __ ] singing old people in
Long Island half of them this is what
happens you get cocky and you start
talking like you're the [ __ ] it's just
to me I just say to myself ah it's not
needed it's not needed it's not mature
it is what it is I have a lot of respect
I see a lot of plays I see a lot of
shows I
watch a lot of people you're not gonna
know who they are but they're [ __ ]
great they're great at what they [ __ ]
do and it's just a little it could be a
little aggravating when out of nowhere
somebody pops up and they tend to think
that they've paid they're paving the way
they're paving the way for people the
ways we pay none of us are paving the
way here it's been paved ru hi ru hi it
it is been pain is pain people are
coming down it's it's good it's good I'm
happy am I making sense yeah yeah yeah
like when we saw the ferryman like in
the front row and there was the the the
was it called when they come out and bow
that yeah you know the curtain call
whatever I forget yeah yeah they come
out yeah it's a three hi seven of
theatres I don't know what it's [ __ ]
call no I'm trying to think need that
the cast call the bow I get work I've
done it more than half these other
people who can make fun of me I can't
think right now [ __ ] just yell over
the Bush family for an hour of scattered
yeah but we saw the yeah what I'm like
embarrassed to be seen by like I don't
even want them to see my face well this
write an article about you that you're
the boss now you're the boss of the five
families they gonna write an article
that you're the boss and you go I'm the
boss now
I didn't shoot nobody I didn't run a
successful operation no racketeering no
gambling no murder no women you do not
but I'm the boss and you know when I
want people well people emulate me they
copied me I say thank you ah God ah god
what are you doing have a little have a
little dignity inject it into yourself
somehow a lot of people that baby on
stage it was a baby
and you were like that baby's done more
than either of us the baby on the
ferryman is done more than me and bad
have done and made more money and is
more essential to the
action in every way no one cares what I
go to Blackbaud if they come out before
me and go today we're gonna have a
magician who does magic with puppets the
audience would go nuts they fall out of
their seats they'd be 2530 P and more
now because more people in knowing where
some of my fans would be a little upset
until he came out and did it did a
little bit with the puppet and then a
lot of them ago it's is it bad is it
we're already here so I'm just saying I
respect a lot of different people a lot
of different kinds of comedy but I just
there's so yeah sometimes people ask me
to do articles or they'll pitch an
article to me they're like how is it
harder as a gay guy in comedy I'm like
I'm not doing this article like what's
it like when a gay guy works comedy
clubs I'm like oh I don't know like tons
of gay guys have done throughout history
what are you talking about right I mean
I remember one gay guy in New York is
like I was the first gay guy to work a
comedy club I'm like you know that's
provably untrue that's completely wrong
you're saying that I get it i I don't I
don't hate on anybody you get all you
could press swidden about you great just
come unless here's the other thing
unless you were kidding maybe you were
kidding when you said that and then if
that was a case I feels the little
stupid now if you were kidding if you
were kidding when you said that it's
kind of funny and well
[Laughter]